I would say that there's a difference  between being selective and having high  standards I think that women and it's  it's if you look at dating up data it's  very well understood that that women are  they will they will swipe less freely  they'll be they'll think more about  their swiping and they'll probably swipe  right less often whereas men if you're  going to stereotype we'll just you know  get they will play the numbers game  um but I wouldn't that's because women  are looking for a man of a certain  height and a certain income I think  they're looking for someone who they  click with more and there just seems to  be a phenomenal woman seem to play the  numbers game more